in a world fueled by Innovation and
driven by technology there exists a
breed of professionals who have the
power to shape the future they are the
AI Engineers The Architects of
intelligence the ones who bridge the gap
between human potential and machines
capability but have you ever wondered
what lies behind the curtain of their
remarkable work today we embark on a
journey to unravel the mysteries of the
AI Engineers world the demand for AI
Engineers has skyrocketed companies
across various sectors are competing to
secure these exception tenants and they
are willing to offer High salary
packages according to Industry reports
the salaries of AI Engineers have been
on a remarkable upward trajectory with
their expertise in high demand AI
Engineers have become one of the most
sought out after professions in the job
market in this video we will cover
topics like the rising demand for AI
ingenious factors affecting air engineer
salary skills required for AI Engineers
salary of AI engineers and companies
hiring for AI engineers
now before moving forward let me ask you
a quick question
what is the term used to describe an AI
system's ability to learn and improve
the experience without being explicitly
programmed
option A is machine learning option b is
artificial neural network option C is
reinforcement learning and option D is
deep learning now you can pause this
video and answer in the comment section
below so let's move on to the first
topic which is the rising demand for a
Engineers the need for AI Engineers is
growing rapidly because of the
increasing popularity of artificial
intelligence we see AI in things like
cars that can drive themselves and
digital assistants like CD Alexa and
Google Assistant
which can understand and respond to
human voice commands providing helpful
information and Performing tasks
AI is becoming more and more common in
our everyday lives and that's why there
is a big demand for AI ingenious these
Engineers have a special mix of
knowledge about technology and skills
for solving problems
with their expertise they can create new
and creative AI Solutions
so in a nutshell the rising demand for
AI Engineers is a result of
transformative impact of AI on various
Industries now let's understand the
factors affecting AI engineer salary
so first is experience
AI Engineers with several years of
hands-on experience in developing air
algorithms and systems command higher
salaries due to their expertise and
track record of successful projects
Junior AI Engineers while earning
relatively less have opportunities for
growth and skill development now second
is location
the geographical location plays a
significant role in determining a
engineer salaries Tech hubs such as
Silicon Valley New York City and London
tend to offer higher salaries due to the
consideration of AI driven companies and
fairs competition for talent third is
educational background the education
background of AI Engineers can greatly
impact their salaries AI Engineers who
have advanced degrees tend to earn
higher salaries employers recognize the
expertise and in-depth understanding and
are willing to offer higher compensation
to attract and retain these highly
qualified professionals so this was
about factors affecting AI engineer
salary
now let's understand about the skills
required for AI engineer
to become an air engineer certain skills
are essential firstly Proficiency in
programming languages such as python are
Java Scala typescript and C plus plus is
crucial these languages are commonly
used in AI development and allow
Engineers to implement and optimize AI
algorithms effectively AI Engineers
should possess expertise in data
handling and Analysis they should be
skilled in collecting cleaning and
manipulating large data sets to train AI
models accurately in terms of machine
learning AI Engineers need a
comprehensive understanding of machine
learning algorithms neural networks and
deep understanding of Frameworks like
tensorflow or Pi torch a strong
Foundation of mathematics is necessary
knowledge of probability statistics
calculus and linear algebra is vital for
AI Engineers these mathematical Concepts
underpin the algorithms and models used
in AI systems and understanding them is
essential for building accurate and
efficient AI models now coming to the
exciting part of this video that is
salary of AI engineer
artificial intelligence engineer in the
United States can expect to earn
salaries within a range of 108
000 to 162 000 with a median salary of
135 000 these figures reflect the
competitive salary packages offered to
Professionals in this field
the salary range takes into account
various factors including experience
location industry and the specific
company
in India the salary range for a
Engineers with less than one year to six
years of experience is between 3 lakhs
to 22 lakhs the average annual salary
for AI engineers in this range is 7.8
lakhs so this was about the salary
packages of AI Engineers now let's
discuss some companies hiring for a
Engineers several prominent companies
are effectively hiring for a Engineers
to fuel their technological advancements
and Innovation these companies recognize
the importance of artificial
intelligence in driving their business
strategies
some notable companies hiring for a
ingenious include so first is Amazon
second is NVIDIA and third is Microsoft
so let's discuss about these
Amazon with 13 of open AI jobs on
Glassdoor Amazon has been at the
Forefront of a integration across its
various Production Services they
prioritize AI Engineers to develop
Cutting Edge Solutions and enhance
customer experiences second is NVIDIA
Nvidia holds six percent of open AI jobs
on Glassdoor enhancing their commitment
to AI research and development
they focus on creating Advanced Hardware
and software solutions to enable AI
driven Technologies in Industries like
gaming autonomous vehicles and data
centers Microsoft a technology giant
possesses four percent of open AI jobs
on Glassdoor they heavily invest in AI
research and development working on
projects like natural language
processing computer vision and machine
learning to empower businesses and
consumers with AI driven solution
IBM IBM has been a significant player in
the AI space for years offering various
AI powered services and products they
continue to hire AI Engineers to expand
their capabilities in areas like Watson
AI cloud computing and data analytics
Accenture as a global Professional
Service Company
leverages AI to transform businesses
across various Industries they hire an
Engineers to develop and Implement AI
strategies focusing on areas such as
intelligent automation data analysis and
AI driven customer experiences
at number six we have Facebook
a leading social media platform actively
recruits AI Engineers to enhance their
AI driven features including content
recommendation systems facial
recognition and natural language
processing so these were the companies
hiring for AI Engineers along with this
there are many more companies that are
actively hiring for a engineers
ultimately pursuing a career as an
engineer offers not only attractive
salaries but also the chance to make a
significant impact in a rapidly
advancing field
as AI continues to shape the future the
expertise and contributions of AI
Engineers will be instrumental in
unlocking new possibilities
this course features master classes by
IBM experts exclusive hackathons to help
you master various skills like
statistics python supervised learning
neural networks NLP and much more by
covering tools and techniques like numpy
pandas and python along with amazing
industry projects so what is stopping
you from building your future in aimml
enroll now the course link is in the
description box alright guys with that
we have come to the end of this video If
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up I hope it will help you all
thanks for watching stay safe and keep
learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign